in a 24-minute court statement this week
britney spears made it clear she's done
playing nice with the conservatorship
that has been dominating her life since
2008.
the arrangement effectively gave control
of her life to her father jamie spears
in her statement britney described a
litany of suffering
from being forced to take lithium
against her will to not being allowed to
remove her iud
she asked the court to have control of
her life back and put an end to the
conservatorship
which has allowed jamie spears to live
off of her 60 million dollar fortune
so how much did jaime spears actually
pocket from britney's earnings
well since february 2008 jamie spears
has been paid at least 5 million dollars
before taxes
and since at least february 2009 a year
after jaime was named conservator in
charge of her estate
he was paid 16 000 a month according to
court documents reviewed by forbes
over 12 years that compensation totals
2.4 million dollars
on top of that brittany has had to pay
hundreds of thousands
if not millions of dollars in legal fees
for both herself
and her conservators she's also paid for
her father's office space
an additional two thousand dollars a
month in rent a report in the new york
times
also pointed to jamie collecting
portions of britney's touring revenue
which could explain britney's
accusations that she was forced to work
despite not wanting to or feeling sick
this includes 1.5 of the gross ticket
and merchandise sales from brittany's
piece of me las vegas residency between
2013 and 2017.
that show brought in 137.7 million
dollars
leaving jamie with a cut of 2.1 million
brittany did not mention the way her
father invested her money or the larger
picture of her finances in court
but she did speak to how her personal
finances were restricted
including the fact that she can't carry
her own credit card
quote it makes no sense whatsoever for
the state of california to sit back and
literally watch me with their own two
eyes make a living for so many people
and pay so many people
trucks and buses on tour on the road
with me and be told i'm not good enough
she told the court
it's been a long time since i've owned
my money and it's my wish
and my dream for all of this to end